this is Startalk you know one of the big
news items recently was the discovery of
a planet that may end up being the
closest planet to us of any of them that
aren't in our own solar system Proxima
beat up tell me a little bit about
Proxima be right that is big news so
there's no maybe about it this planet is
definitely the closest planet to the Sun
that's not orbiting the Sun so the star
is called Proxima we used to always call
it Proxima Centauri which is just Latin
for the closest thing in the
constellation of the center but now we
know that it's actually the very closest
star to the Sun anywhere so it's planets
really are the closest so we've been
finding planets around other stars in
the galaxy for a little over 20 years
now and thanks to space missions like
the Kepler space telescope we now know
of thousands of planets in the galaxy
and this one though is different it's
special because it's really our neighbor
and so we're going to be studying this
one in particular because it's right
there forever basically and we're going
to be wondering about it and how to get
there and what we can learn about it
what would you say it's the closest one
I mean maybe we ought to give them own
number for that how far where is it so
stars are really really far away to get
technical about it this one being being
closed is a little over 4 light years
away so if you could ride on a light
beam then it would only take you four
years to get there so in cosmic terms
that's they're our neighbors they're
right next door I like beans yeah I
would love to ride on a light beam as a
matter of fact that's going to be the
name of my next album riding on a light
beam but Chuck nice that's not so it so
give us an idea of four light years
let's let's let's let's break that down
into human terms how long would it take
us to get there well if we got our best
Rockets launch foot probe into
interstellar space and we've done this
before so you know we know we could do
that
let's see it would take something like I
don't know a hundred thousand years to
get there maybe tens of thousands of
years if we went really fast yeah I
figure about a hundred thousand is right
I mean that's a long time to be eating
peanuts off your lap in the middle team
right so five thousand years to get it
yeah but I mean it isn't to say that you
couldn't get there faster I mean if you
if you don't want to go yourself and you
just want to send some sort of object
maybe the size of a silver dollar or
something like that to price you could
do that faster good you well in
principle right I mean this used to be
all science fiction but you know
recently people have thought hard about
this there's a project called
breakthrough starshot which is trying to
figure out how to do exactly that so
there's this old idea that if you gave a
spaceship of sail a light sail so just
like a big parachute or something and
then you shot a really powerful laser
beam at that parachute you could
accelerate something really fast and it
takes a really powerful laser beam to
launch something that could have a
person in it but if you only wanted to
launch like a tiny little microchip or
something like that something that
weighs less than a raisin then you would
only need a super-powered laser about a
square kilometer across well that's a
very modest requirement